Welcome back to Google
Developers Weekly
for February 3, 2014.
I'm Louis Gray, and this
is our highlight reel
of what's happening in the
world of Google Developers,
on the set and off.
Since the introduction of
version 3 of the YouTube data
API, many developers are
migrating from version 2,
as you might expect.
From New York, Jeff
Posnick walks us
through the API
calls you need to get
a list of the videos
uploaded in a given channel,
featuring live demos
using the API Explorer.
You can learn this and
more at youtube.com/dev.
In our second event,
highlighting Orbitz integration
with Google Wallet,
Yousef Attalla of Orbitz
joins Maru Bouza to demonstrate
how their customers earn
and track loyalty
points called Orbucks
using the Orbitz and
Google Wallet Apps.
Alex Maier, Community Manager
for Google Cloud Platform,
took the stage here
in Mountain View
to announce live the winners
of the Google Cloud Developer
Challenge.
There were 12 winners from
6 regions of the world.
Did you win, or you want
to find out who did?
Check it out, and if anybody
asked, I voted for you.
Tomorrow's great apps are going
to come from minds much younger
than my own, and the best
way to get the kids coding
is to teach them how early.
Developer advocate
Julia Ferraioli
spoke with Ashley
Galvin about her work
with girls who code, and
how she develops curricula
that appeals to everyone.
And our GDL weekly
wrap-ups would not
be complete without
another appearance
from our Udacity CS256
mobile web dev team.
Chris Wilson, Sean
Bennett, and Peter Lubbers
are back with a third
edition of Office Hours
tackling lessons 6 and 7.
You can cram in our YouTube
channel and find out more
at udacity.com/course/cs256.
In addition to all
this great stuff,
the Android developers
team brought us
new DevBytes, focused
on recording out videos,
and our personal favorite, best
practices for playing games.
As far as I see it, any game
I win was designed perfectly.
Check them out at
developers.google.com/live/android.
Also, Dart fans got a new
release of the Dart Editor
in the dev channel this week.
Lots of cool new features,
including the start for support
for Angular and
Json Quick Assist.
Check it all out
at dartlang.org.
And to make sure you never
miss a thing from the world
of Google Developers, subscribe
to Google Developers on YouTube
and check out the GDL schedule
at developers.google.com/live.
I'm Louis Gray, and I'll
see you in the studio.